[Music]
good morning ladies and gentlemen i'm
guessing that some of you you're not
happy maybe you don't fit in people make
fun of you
well i can't make you straight
but you give us this week and we might
be able to
help boys cabin over there girls cabin
over there i use they them pronouns as
in they can't believe they're at this
camp
i have zero interest in not being gay
there's no judgments in this room
sometimes always sure was invisible
i would understand it a lot more if
there was bible thumping and queer
bashing do you even believe in any of
this
come in please
do you think your parents are
disappointed in you sometimes so what do
you do you try to make yourself
special
you
become
they
today we're going to be exploring
traditional gender roles
look how long they've been doing this
it's time to play this could get a lot
worse
where's my killer
we need to get out of here
just enjoy the sunshine and work on your
tan
they
slash them
streaming only on peacock august 5th
[Music]